so watch the mind of Jake Paul like all
of it which is weird because YouTube
drama no I had a big part of my life
what I was interested in this because it
looks like we're living at a time where
the entertainment of YouTube starting to
become more legit it's a big moneymaker
there's YouTube Brad not gonna like
Tobruk I might actually make it on my
top 10 favorite movies at 2018 not a
movie not even in theaters but you know
what it's my list look Jake Paul's a
name I've seen a lot of usually tied
with drama tied with hate I kind of want
to see the other side of it so I'm gonna
talk about it so the mind of Jake Paul
is an 8 part documentary series on Shane
Dawson's channel that Shane Dawson made
on YouTube in which the last part is
twice as long as any other episode so
it's kind of a nine part series sort of
for calling it an eight part series what
I mean is it's a five part series about
Jake Paul in a three part series which
is Shane Dawson making a sales pitch of
hey I want to make documentaries about
sociopaths and they kind of got some
heat at first for it being really overly
dramatic playing the music like the
eerie music he's talking about
sociopaths you could feel like they're
among us then they also are impulsive so
failure to plan ahead they'll want to do
things and then not do things on a whim
yes they are among us doesn't mean
they're killing people just sociopaths
exist and at first when he was like his
Jake Paul a sociopath I was like this is
a question to ask because that's kind of
you know the burn is someone's acting
like an [ __ ] on YouTube there will be
comments directed at them like oh that
person's a little psychopath or that
person's a little sociopath so I like
the fact that he was addressing it and I
was like maybe he's gonna address it to
squash it but it just kept on it that
conversation literally went for three
parts at a point it was hijacking the
entire conversation about Jake Paul it
was all completely hypothetical and
overdramatize I just felt like it was
the wrong foot to start out on I can't
really add anything to the conversation
because a lot of people have said that
oh really in part four they sit down
with one of Jake Paul's former friends
and colleagues Nick Nick Compton
crompton not really down on team ten I
just wanted to see a documentary there
now that I've dedicated nine hours to it
i'ma talk about it here I'm gonna call
him Nick cuz I'm terrible at last names
anyhow Shane asked Nick he's like is
Jake Paula sociopath he's like now I've
seen him be touched and hurt over things
so right there I was like all right so
the last three hours of this thing are
completely obsolete I don't even know
why it happened or was capped at that
point like when you're filming a
documentary series you're gonna run into
stuff that you film and then later on
you find out that information is just
not really relevant anymore so it ends
up on the cutting room floor why didn't
the first three hours of this thing end
up on the cutting room floor I don't
know I really they have this therapist
who's on YouTube names Katie bad with
last name I'm gonna call her Katie
because we're cool like that
never met her she doesn't even know who
I am but she's the one that Shane Dawson
is talking to when Shane Dawson's like
is Jake Palo sociopath hmm
dramatic music and when they're actually
at Jake Paul's place she's undercover
she's a therapist but they don't tell
him he's a therapist but she's analyzing
it which really wasn't necessary he was
just talking with the guy like it seems
pretty normal and then at the very end
gonna jump ahead for a second the very
end the last episodes like an hour and
40 minutes of Jake Paul there are no
walls anymore he's just being railed
things are really affecting him he's he
looks sad when he's talking looks like
he's about to cry Erica had like come
into my life to like teach me how to
like love and like and like and like
trust again and yeah it's been a lot I
was just thinking if you wanted a part
in this series to have a therapist if
you're looking for the opportune moment
that was it but at that point Shane
Dawson is really giving him advice and I
feel like a therapist it would have been
good to have one in the room maybe they
had one in the room but they just
weren't on camera the whole thing like
if I could describe this series in a
nutshell it's like cribs meets dr. Phil
as I say and I think a lot of people are
gonna say the serious really kind of
starts out in episode 4 episode 3 is not
a complete wash because it talks about
the family and Greg Paul can't talk
about the product of the children
without talking about the family in the
upbringing and really at that point
that's when I started to feel for Jake
Paul's like oh that sucks a huge take
away a hat from this was the large and
grand
also empty side to youtube fame when
they're talking to Nick it's in this one
house and it has a pool with Hollywood
over it it literally says Hollywood over
the pool in this mansion then when
they're talking to Jake Paul's ex it's
like the exact same house but I guess
it's not the exact same house I don't
know if it's the same architect designer
or the same house what is when you're
watching it you really feel like this is
their life this studio space is exactly
like that studio space only it looks
like a mansion it looks like a living
space but really it's studio space and
they really don't have a place to call
their own it just feels empty as [ __ ]
you have a lot of roommates in a big
house but really it's all one big
business arrangement [ __ ] that I don't
know the big house would be neat and all
but I'd be there for a bet and then I'd
be like all right amount and really you
see Jake Paul's house he has a lot of
friends living there they're living
there for free essentially it just seems
like it's a big manchild like he wants
to create his little bubble of
happiness where all his friends hang out
like can you blame him no like the
world's nice out there it's not like he
gets a lot of love online why wouldn't
he create a little fortress that's
essentially his happy place really kind
of looks like to me Jake Paul is young
and as he's young he's done stupid [ __ ]
but people are supposed to be allowed to
be young and dumb so they can grow and
be better people only thing is he was
young and dumb on YouTube with a huge
following so really that shit's gonna
follow him for a very long time if not
forever like a lot of YouTube
personalities who've been doing this for
a while they've said or done some [ __ ]
they're not proud of I mean if I'm using
my own experience when I was starting on
my youtube channel you look at my old
channel the jokes and there were really
dark really edge Lord [ __ ] that's what I
wanted to be I wanted to be the edge
Lord that cracked jokes that made people
knuckle up as a result of that mindset
mixed with ignorance on this channel
I've done some jokes that went too far
couple in particular I look back on and
I'm like if I could undo that I would I
am definitely not proud of that there
are no time machines all you can do with
your past and those moments in your past
that you're not proud of is learn from
your past to grow in your present so you
can be better in the future so that's
what I try to do and I bring this up
because I feel like that's what Jake
Paul wants to do so I kind of empathize
with him there but it's so easy to throw
hate at someone for something you did
that's on camera on his channel even if
that is in the past it's easy to deal
with it as if it happened yesterday like
Jake Paul didn't like school didn't like
his teachers is one scenario where he's
talking about that now I see what he's
trying to say the public school system
could definitely use some refining it
teaches a certain kind of person to
learn a certain kind of way a lot of
other people they struggle myself
included so when his Jake Paul way he
addresses that in a music video he makes
like a diss track so he puts it in a
song and now it's out there like imagine
you have a certain mindset about a
certain something let's say at school
that say it's teachers so you talk to
someone about that you phrase it a
certain way then later your mindset
changes on it or maybe you refine your
thoughts so the next person you talk to
you talk about it a different way but in
Jake Paul's case the person he talked to
was a camera and now it's a music video
it's a song with lyrics it's now written
in video stone so later on when his
mindset changes or now that his mindset
has changed people can and will be like
no that's your mindset cuz it's there in
the video you said that so it's hard for
a public personality that deals with
video to change their mind about
something people always deal with
present YouTube person how their video
of the past presents them even though
people are always constantly changing
and evolving
I just empathize with that I do and it
felt like it might be a self-sustaining
ball of energy of circular reasoning
that point someone does something they
get hate you give them hate you treat
them like an animal they're gonna act
like an animal they're gonna do more
[ __ ] that guess I'm hating it just goes
around and runnin around which is why
I'm glad Shane Dawson made this
documentary series because this is
essentially the way anyone would sit
down and be like all right let's hear
his side of it I mean what if Jake Paul
made a video about Jake Paul I wouldn't
give a [ __ ] I'd never watched it the big
takeaway I hope people would have from
this whole thing is you just reflect on
how easy it is to fall into that wheel
of hate like someone or a collective of
people we've already collectively made
up our minds to hate someone so we're
gonna hate them forever oh really they
do have their story here's the
mind-bending thing those people big or
small people who are largely
collectively hated or maybe someone you
dislike at a personal level they can
have a documentary or interview made
about them it's made to show their side
of it that will make the people who hate
them go oh I didn't think about that I
kind of get it I kind of see where
they're coming from maybe you don't like
it but you'll at least know why they
came to that conclusion funny thing is
you don't need a documentary to do that
I just hope going forward in life people
are more receptive to that concept like
if someone just says something or tweet
something that irritates you just it
enrages you maybe you don't retweet it
to get your mob going after them maybe
talk to them be like hey what do you
mean by that what's your side of it
let's be more interested in having a
conversation rather than just raging out
on people it's really outrageous
outrageous doesn't help anyone doesn't
help anyone become better anyway just
talking does and I feel like humanity as
a whole collectively we will be better
in the future if our goal is to have
conversations rather than just burn
people to the ground and I'm not making
excuses for everything Jake Paul is done
in fact I don't even know everything
Jake Paul's done people watching this
probably know more about his
controversies than I now I just know
what I saw in this video what I saw in
this video someone who at least wants to
grow up if not at least make an attempt
to move past it as in the end I enjoyed
the mind of Jake Paul if for nothing
else I really like the fact that Shane
Dawson forced the world or at least
people on YouTube to take a look at the
other side to take a look at the side of
someone who's generally he gets a lot of
hate on YouTube but what's his side of
it interestingly enough people generally
don't take that beat and take that step
to take the effort to look at the
perspective of someone they're
essentially made to hate with this
documentary series like we have - and he
does show a lot of size of it this is a
lot of YouTube drama
a lot of he-said she-said which hey
that's the one hey of 2008 a lot of it I
don't know much about cuz like I said
now
really down with YouTube drama I just
wanted to know more about a person it
was entertaining first and foremost I
suppose that's what you want from
something like this it was also
informative in terms of perspective
seeing Jake Paul side of it that side of
it being a side that a lot of people
were like I don't care for a long time
but did you think the sociopath thing
was the wrong foot to start out on if
you're gonna bring it up bring it up
briefly if you don't have to linger on
it for too long maybe bring it up then
talk to his friend who's like no he's
not you just move on and talk about
other stuff I have this so see a bad
thing hijack the ride for three hours
Shane Dawson uses background music to
create a tone to elicit a response in
perspective as documentaries do that
seems to be the nature of the filmmaker
Shane Dawson comes across as very easy
very dramatic person even the teasers
and coming next time even those are kind
of clicked Beatty and dramatic implies
that there's hidden cameras Jake Paul
didn't know about there isn't implies is
gonna be the controversy there's not
even the trailer - the whole thing shows
Shane Dawson I like what do you what do
you mean when he finds out that you've
painted him in a very accessible and
relatable light yeah I'm sure he's gonna
be really pissed I was really interested
in the family dynamic the living dynamic
the business dynamic of it all son Shane
Dawson's channel put a link below to the
first episode and then a link under that
to the fourth episode however you want
to start it out it was an interesting
look at perspective I've heard a lot of
hate even in my comments section about
Jake Paul I don't even talk about the
guy but it's been there and is usually a
Logan Paul's bad but Jake Paul's worse I
know just maybe he's just another one of
us another one of me another one of you
just another person trying to figure it
all out
making mistakes to trip ups along the
way but hopefully by the end of this
ride we figure it out or at least a part
of it if Shane Dawson wants to do a
documentary series on sociopaths or
psychology or something like that I'd
actually be interested in checking that
out I just hope he learns from this
documentary series as to what to do and
what not to do and maybe things that he
could improve on later if the first part
of this was a test run for that
guess that's what test rooms are for
right so the mind of Jake Paul have you
seen it what did you think about it
whatever you thought comment below let
me know and as always if you like what
you've seen here and you want to see
more click right here to see more
[Music]